so we looked at a Native American
religion just a little bit not in any
sort of systematic way in Chapter one
now we're revisiting it in chapter 21
and you know in the United States Native
Americans would fit up here what in
religious studies we call indigenous
religions so we're talking about you
know religions of tribal peoples in
Africa and Asia and Polynesia and places
like that and they all kind of get
lumped in together and it's one thing to
look at them sort of in the abstract
yeah separate from from everything else
but a lot of times I think you guys
probably realize this by now religions
are interacting with each other they're
not existing in a vacuum and all sorts
of non-religious forces have have a role
on what happens so that's part of what's
going on in the story in this chapter we
were looking at Christian missions
because you know why well it was only
Christians carrying enough Jews were not
interested in converting Native
Americans and Christians were pretty
much the only game in town
that they're divided into a bunch of
different denominations and we'll talk
about how that played out but you know
that's the main dynamic going on and
your book talks about you know where did
you know what do they think about the
Native Americans do they do they
understand where they came from the
answer is no right
at first its total missed recognition
why does Columbus call them Indians he's
where yeah the actually thought he hit
India and after a while he realized his
mistake and that's not really what we're
worried about
what we're more interested in is how did
missions work how did they play out what
sort of effects that they have and one
of the things that we want to do is
distinguish between
a couple different models national
models the the Spanish approached things
differently than the French did who
approached things differently then
English din and the English were divided
into a couple of different groups and
even with the Spanish you have a couple
different some models play themselves
out the way they approach Native
Americans if they were Franciscans was
different than if they're Jesuits
remember when we talk about Catholicism
there's these religious orders this is
when that sort of thing starts to starts
to matter so your book begins by by
talking about a couple different agents
or players on the scene one of the
things you want to you want to avoid
when you're thinking about Christian
Native American interactions is lumping
everybody into one category because
that's just sort of sloppy work it's
like thinking with the Spanish who would
be the main people on the scene don't
just think about religion think about
who are the Spaniards that are coming
over here and doing doing things and one
way around the positive the negative so
we know what you have right but who else
who else is a player yeah yeah and what
does that translate to exactly yeah they
were there to conquer solo replace the
realm of explorers but they were
exploring basically to conquer things
mainly looking for gold or other other
valuable items a lot of the way they
started realizing hey use these it's
easily paraphrase a title Guns Germs and
Steel give us an incredible advantage
over these native civilizations so we're
going to take them over we're gonna
fight them horses help to
who else plays a role but not directly
on the scene would be the Spanish state
or crowd yeah all three of these might
have different different goals different
aims the conquistadors are interested in
striding well power and how did they
treat the Native Americans they enslaved
many of them they killed many of them
they were not particularly interested
learning anything about their cultures
the king you know or queen depending on
what time we're talking about is back in
Spain doesn't have a lot of local
control any local control that would be
exercised that the governors and
governor's power would only extend as
far as their soldiers went but they're
mostly interested in what keeping order
making sure that things don't you know
completely degenerate and then even the
conquistadors might not see eye to eye
the clergy what are they interested in
they have a whole different agenda what
are they all about just say Mass you
guys get into it cuz I'm like saying
saying that's the Native Americans just
as much fun probably not all right what
is their goal what do they want to do
this is issued mission well sir what's
their whole way of life in that think
about if you want to be a priest you got
to give up a lot of stuff don't you
that was your Catholic priest other
priests - no sex for you getting vows of
obedience if you're in a religious order
may not like we're obedient to poverty
quite often that's a lot to give up why
do people do this they just needed a
place
they think so what what attracted them
especially going overseas incentive you
know hanging out in Spain or at least
you know what things are like and
everybody speaks the language
why go over to the wilds of America
where the food bike killya the animals
bike Illya the diseases might kill you
I do all that I react distant from this
sort of time that it's hard to to relate
to their their motives people still go
on mission work today
just Medicaid last week is going on
missioned ironically who's going on
mission to England I guess I did they
become Saudi Christianized that people
send in missions to European countries
now they want to they want to bring
Christianity right I mean other kinky
Sumerians Christianity they bring a fire
and sword they cross the same day I'm
probably not going to be you know
connected with Jesus Christ in any
tangible way is that is the king
generally you use that the hands of the
clergy so the the question is that how
do you actually bring Christianity to
Native Americans and there's a couple
different models for this and so this
with the Spanish we can talk about three
different models that your book goes
over talking about Mexico and in Mexico
you had a very highly developed
civilization the latest rulers of which
on the scene where the Aztecs actually
the Aztecs were so brutal that the other
people were praying for the Aztecs would
be overthrown because you know they've
been just succession after succession of
civilization when Cortes can't some
other people actually welcomed him
because they didn't like the Aztecs but
then if they know much about Cortes they
probably you know when the minutes old
welcoming the Spanish wants the clergy
show up they try to superimpose the
Catholic
Catholic Church and all of its rituals
and all of its ideas on to sort of an
Aztek basis so I could took your book
mentions they tried to superimpose the
material presence of their religion of
the remains of the shrines of the Aztecs
so the Cathedral in Mexico City prime
example it's actually erected on the
scene of one of the temples this is not
a new thing by the way Christians did
this in Europe when they when they took
over some of those at that time pagan
areas when they were carrying out
conversion they would they would build a
church on top of the site of an ancient
temple so like the book says they were
there opposing their own version of
cosmos we've talked about this before
the cosmology order to what they
perceived as the chaos of being average
in all habitations and this also allowed
them to create administrative units to
put things into a settled state now they
they thought that what they were doing
was imposing this on the chaos the chaos
is just a mixture of things for the
Aztecs they already had a very complex
developed civilization they actually had
a cosmology as a matter of fact they
thought they were living in the fifth
age there was an entire succession of
destruction of the world and then
rebirth of the world different gods were
in charge of it and somebody has
actually actually said that the coming
of the Spanish was the destruction of
the fifth world and the beginning of the
sixth book doesn't really talk about
that but it's an interesting sidedness
now these missionaries tried to do like
they said master the native languages
and devised new not new approaches to
evangelization two approaches to
converting to bring us
Christianity tonight so you know
open-air churches where something you
can do in that area why because it
doesn't rain all the time it's a pretty
dry
what are they successful according these
these native languages only partially
and it's really because of the
missionaries and they're writing things
down that we have many of them records
the Aztecs for example but they were
only partially successful yeah but the
book points out the Spanish clergy
regarded the Indians is perpetually
dependent and the order they imposed on
their charges was what we call
paternalistic is this a term you guys
are familiar with paternalism when
somebody's paternalistic they're
treating you like a child like very you
know you're you're their kid they're the
day I used to be that colleges were like
that
so perhaps you still have advisors that
are kind of paternalistic they don't let
you pick your own classes and they tell
you well you're going to take this and
this and this that would be what we're
talking about here now so many other
approaches that the Spanish had can be
looked at in terms of other geographical
so we've known from a place with immense
city-states and now we want to look at
somewhat less developed at least in
material culture civilizations so now
we're looking at the American Southwest
New Mexico and there we have a number of
different peoples that are all sort of
locked into this classification of the
Pueblo
the Hopi are a particularly good example
how many of you have gone to a museum
because you see a lot of this in museums
and seen Hopi Kachina or artwork or
have any of you seen these sorts of
things you can find them and to go down
to the city History Museum you'll see
this sort of stuff
that's worth taking a look at because
those Cucina they're both dolls and and
masks and they're part of these
societies and that's part of the
ancestral religion that these people
were practicing there's a lot of really
sophisticated discussions about exactly
what do they symbolize and how do they
work and do they both at the people
believe that these these objects really
have any any you know in inherent power
or are they merely symbolic and
representative they could find a lot of
great discussion of that the
missionaries that went in those areas
like like your book points out really
did not do a good job in producing
conversion why not well because they
just trying to impose Christianity by
force and you know how it is when
somebody tells you what to do you don't
want to do it they impose it by force
does that make you want to do it anymore
not usually and if you already have
anyone standing you know very tightly
knit groove you can probably resist for
a very long time and the way that a lot
of people do this this sort of
resistance is by what your book calls
compartmentalize so you tell people one
thing and then you go off and do another
thing and that's what they would do the
the people and the priests for these
ancestral religions would continue their
rights in secret and tell the priests
yeah sure you know whatever you say
father I'll go to Mass I'll get baptized
but then they said then none of that
matters we're gonna keep doing this over
here and so they you know the
missionaries trying to stamp this sort
of thing out but they were they're
highly unsuccessful and Christianity
didn't leave much of a mark predictably
so your book talks about the
organization of their their voluntary
societies and you know I leave that to
you to read and think about another
approach is what happened in California
how many of you ever been out to
California and see the missions
California yeah so they talk about this
is Royal Road and then they talk about
these mission churches along there and
each of these mission churches was
supposed to be about one one days you
know March away from the other so they
could be in contact with each other
yeah this was a difference this was a
different model that the Spaniards were
doing there so there's this guy Junipero
Serra he organizes all these missions 21
mission stations along this this Royal
Road from San Diego to San Francisco and
what does he do there he invites the the
native inhabitants to come and help him
that he doesn't try to convert them he
doesn't you know get up there and say
this is the book you must believe in
everybody line up for baptism and
studying he says hey I need some help
building these these buildings would you
mind helping me out and you can see sort
of this fusion going on because part of
the architecture is definitely Spanish
and part of it is adapted to the local
circumstances
now once once these these missions are
being built like he says the compounds
are designed to be self-sustaining each
of these is supposed to be its own
little community
yeah and they began to follow and it was
it was quite successful under the
Franciscan tutelage the natives raised
cattle sheep all of grape and other
produce now notice our grapes native to
where there's wild grapes but our grapes
of the sort that he's talking about
native to California or olives
he's transplanting a lot of Spanish
culture there and he's offering it as
something that they can they can make
part of their own life at the same time
he's instructing them in the rudiments
of Christianity he's not demanding that
they do that but he's doing that mission
priest so this is the European priests
coming in were expected to master the
native language within a year of their
arriving and they have to print out to
be something very important for
conversions that also had to do with the
French and to a lesser extent with the
English if you expect other people to
adapt themselves to your language and if
their languages are very different you
know they may see the world a very
different class if you don't learn their
language it's much less likely that
they're going to take you seriously you
have to be able to adapt your concepts
into other people's language this is a
basic of communication right you've
learned this in your speech classes you
have to adapt yourself to the audience
so that's what they were doing now why
did this fall apart because they no
longer exist as communities today
well once Mexico is a state to come and
they engage in secularization of the
settlements that means that they turn
them into no longer religious
establishments but state establishments
and then when the Americans came and
they did the same thing and the
community just sort of died out so
unfortunately they weren't any more
successful in converting people either
so what about the French the French are
in a different area different areas the
Spanish are dealing with some areas
where you've got massive Siddhi state
civilizations with millions of
inhabitants then you know these Pueblo
villages the French aren't healing
areas where a lot more hunting gathering
is going on some semi-nomadic
civilizations where they pick up steaks
every so often the her on would be a
good example in terms of that and the
french are there for other reasons the
spanish you know we're looking for gold
they wanted to take over areas
eventually colonization becomes a major
thing the french were there to get one
thing well really two main things that's
a beginner what is is to get highs to
get further some trading comes and the
other was to carry out conversions and
with the french the ones who are
particularly successful are the Jesuits
the black rose the Jesuits have sort of
checkered history in france every once
in a while they would you know get a
little too political and get themselves
in trouble
they actually got themselves in trouble
with the papacy a couple times to your
pope mentions the the Jesuits going to
china and trying to translate the Bible
into Chinese that actually sawed off a
huge page diversity because they use the
word for heaven 10/2 to represent God
because there wasn't you know in the
adequate concept of monotheistic
conception and you know people were
saying these Jesuits they go a little
bit too native they adapt themselves a
little bit too much to the local
cultures but then made them particularly
strong when it came to to blending in to
to forming communities that were
Christian communities but also at the
same time indigenous communities so they
talked about a couple different examples
of this one in particular that we want
harass and here we see again that
outside forces even when you are
successful in carrying out mission work
outside forces can come in in and
destroy it because when he happens the
the Hurons
our mission eyes by the Jesuits like it
says they began to work among her ons
beginning at 1625 they said about
learning a language and immersing
themselves in native culture just to
give you an idea of how the Jesuits work
first generation of the guys on the
scene think of them as the advance team
they wouldn't try to convert anybody you
know what they would do figure out you
know what's why learn the language you
can't do anything until they actually
know what people are saying they've
learned the language they've learned the
culture and they learn how to cook the
food that the people ate they would
start to mix with them quite often they
would attain some sort of status in
those societies whether it was you know
a complex society like China or you know
tribal society like the firaon then the
second generation would come in this is
a really quite brilliant the first guys
would brief that they would say here
here's the grammar that I developed of
this language learning because you're
going to need it
and they were the ones who were then I'm
going to start carrying out the mission
work and that by the third generation
you'd have two generations of people
there who had long-standing ties with
the Native community who knew the
language who could tell you as you're
coming in here's what you have to watch
out for and don't eat this by the way
because it's gonna make you sick and see
that guy over there he's an important
person to talk to and here's the
background assumptions that you need to
keep in mind so they were they were
extraordinarily successful when they
didn't run into outside problems in the
case of the qur'an's the outside
problems came in terms of their
ancestral enemy who decided to try to
wipe the her on out and they were pretty
successful
they destroyed the her on you know
society effectively has any sort of
viable you know alternative to them yeah
and they ended up killing a lot of the
missionaries two of the process your
book talks without John the book and how
he was actually admired by the Iroquois
because he stood up to their torture and
some of the tortures that they had were
pretty horrific bless you but this is
you know so in a way this is successful
but in a way it's also unsuccessful so
let's try now about what's different
between the French English and Spanish
right off the bat the French and the
Spanish between the counters right we'll
be talking about this with respect to
the English yeah so we're talking about
a variety of Protestants you know when
it comes to Catholics you can say well
at least they're all supposed to be on
the same page seven sacraments apostolic
succession Pope over there involved all
that sort of stuff right and we see that
there's a lot of variance even with
Catholics but with Protestants they're
not all members of the same church
they've already split apart from each
other so they may have very different
approaches towards the Native Americans
and that's what we see them actually
doing so you know we look at the
Puritans did the Puritans managed to do
much not really in part because most
Puritans were totally uninterested in
converting the Native Americans they you
know in theory Native Americans could go
to heaven it might be part of the
Society of the saints but it's an awful
lot of work to try to communicate with
them your book does talk about this guy
John Eliot and the Bay Colony
notice what he does one of the first
things that he does is produce a grammar
and a dictionary of the massachusett
language translates the new test
and other Christian works into their
language so he's doing the same sort of
pattern that rendered people like the
Jesuits successful but he's doing it as
a Protestant and he organizes them into
these these praying towns
now in these praying towns they're
pretty much expected to give up a lot of
their native american identity but the
catholics are demanding quite a bit of
the same as well once again we see
outside forces praying towns coming in
with the praying towns have been an
effective experiment we don't know why
not well because the war breaks out and
they take a lot of the Native Americans
who are in the praying towns and put
them into concentration camps and the
prank town's effectively cease to exist
along with those people also who died
these these concentration camps what
else he talks about some other some
other missionaries who have you know
very little little success
a few Native Americans went to Harvard
found out that it was you know they were
being told you have to give up being a
Native American and some of them
actually died at Harvard because of the
difficulty of adapting themselves to
that it sounds kind of strange ready to
go to school and I but you know think
about it if you have a particular diet a
way of life that you're adapted to and
you're forced into a radically different
way of life that can have severe
physical nights and that's what happens
he does talk about a few other things
these these meridians we've encountered
before remember they're they're part of
the Anabaptist tradition among the peace
churches and the meridians actually the
hiatus tradition right they influenced
by the Baptist's the meridians carry out
mission work among them
somewhat successful but then what
happens in book tells you they have to
leave these towns during the Revolution
when they come back the frontiersman
Massacre the the Native Americans so
that fails as well the the Quakers
friends carry the opposition work and
again successful beginnings but a lot of
times these these things were just found
it so what's the common theme so far
nothing really has worked particularly
well in terms of providing some sort of
distinct you know some sort of well two
things something that would actually
provide a way in which Native Americans
would not have to give up all of their
identity and yet could become Christians
that would be in fellowship with with
European Christians
none of these experiments are completely
successful after that after the
Revolution we enter a new phase and in
this new phase I think your book talks
about the Protestant churches channel
their their work through this in
traditional American Board of
Commissioners of foreign missions
because they they saw that you know the
frontier is part of foreign territory
and like it says the efforts of
Protestant missionaries were not very
productive why because there's this
insistence that you have to completely
change your way of life that religion
equals culture so taking on the the
religion means getting rid of indigenous
culture and your book gives you a lot of
examples of this so I don't know another
thing that that causes a lot of
disruption with this is the reservation
policy so what did what is that talking
about a little bit later
Native Americans there's a shift in
what's going on in the federal
government they're placing them on
reservations and reservation sounds kind
of good
it's like you know set aside for you but
what kind of land where they usually
reserved for the Native Americans back
here and I remember from their history
classes yeah as the frontiersman are
pushing out they would claim land
usually this is how conflicts would
start the military would usually say
European whites whatever you want to the
same don't go any further than this
because this is say Cherokee territory
or this is Lakota territory here this is
where and what do you think the the
Americans did the white Americans they
just go out there and start settling and
then pretty soon they're settling on
somebody else's land that's like an open
provocation and soon enough there'd be
some conflict between them and then the
military would come in and the military
would take the site against the Native
Americans and the popular perception was
you can't you know these these Native
Americans we've got to do something
about them because they're so warlike so
we'll push them off with a good way out
onto this marginal and the reservations
now in terms of religious why was that
important well the reservations were
divided up by this this Quaker policy
that sort of apportioned different
reservations to different religious
denominations so the Quakers might be in
charge of this one not that it's in
charge of this one the biskits aliens in
charge of this one they did the same
thing by the way in Africa in Nigeria
this policy was tried in the logging
different places yeah and they didn't
pay any attention to who had mission
eyes these people beforehand
yeah the Roman Catholics felt kind of
put out by this so they organized their
own mission boards like like it says in
general the history of this has not been
very successful there is a sort of
bright note towards the very end when
there's
about Catholic missionary work and we're
using the example of the Lakota so
Catholics Catholics and by the way
Lutheran's and we're also out there
doing a mission one Catholics are out
there and until the time of the Attica
to really what it's consisting it is is
trying to be Indian eyes
the natives trying to take away their
identity from that and force them into
schools where they're only speaking
English and essentially trying to
eliminate their identity
as you can guess totally unsuccessful
does not work since managing to laker
book points out the atmosphere of
pluralism that spread through the
Catholic Church led to a different
mythology that's a kind of useful word
to know Missy ology means the philosophy
of mission work what are you up to and
in carrying out missions so the Jesuits
kind of led the charge on that once
again and you see a lot of a lot of
things well you here's some examples
some of them on so far as to participate
in traditional soup practices part of
you know Lakota religion like Vision
Quest and sweat lodge ceremonies there's
a book by the way if you're interested
in it called the pipe in Christ which
talks quite a bit about this it's
actually by a guy who was a Jesuit
missionary and tries to you know find
parallels between the sacraments and the
seven religious ceremonies and talks
about that sort of thing so you might go
to some vanity to you might go to the
reservation and see increased actually
performing the mass in traditional
Native American gear and that would be
considered you know okay for the most
part of what are we looking at here
mostly a tragedy the the interaction
between these these
to remain groups you could say didn't
work out that well yeah we're going to
revisit Native Americans a little bit
later this is something to keep in mind
why the ghost dance you know would
become popular because they the Native
Americans were so alienated by what was
going on at mission work that they might
want something very different